[Music]
the ship is totally repaired
we can finally leave this [ __ ]
planet
so long earth suckers enjoy the melting
ice cap
no no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
damn it hey we're still trapped on earth
this puts us right back to where we were
a year ago oh my god make a bigger deal
about it
i'm just glad everything is back to
normal yo dork
are you crazy where are your masks i
didn't know we needed masks i've been
breathing hair for over a year
let's get the hell out of here quick
grab a scooter
what the [ __ ] is that it's called big
take energy and when i get it i'll be
unstoppable i don't know
a big dick seems really dangerous run
everyone i can't control
we have to help them looks like the
solar opposites are going to london i
could go wrong
suck my butt officer [ __ ] the solar
opposites are
going to jail
he doesn't have a hole we'll just have
to make one
how are we still so bad at this i don't
want to point fingers at the weak link
here but get your [ __ ] together
this is gonna be awesome we're in the
big city you can be anything you want
out here
superhero politician orthodontist a
prostitute
you wanna have some fun sugar no [ __ ]
way
[Music]
[Music]
we're turning people into wines these
people love wine look how happy they are
on the labels
[Music]
you